Tuscany why don't you put salt in your
bread I have a few theories one is that
Florence he's kind of far from the
coastline so they didn't have access to
salt that doesn't really hold up there's
a lot of Inland places that have salt in
their bread another theory is that all
the food eaten in this area is so extra
salty that eating it with bread with no
salt is actually like it balances it all
out although there's lots of other parts
of Italy that also eat similarly salty
food but they still put salt in their
bread the last Theory the salt War back
in like 1540 the pope raised taxes on
salt in one important Italian city and
the people were like that will just stop
salting our bread oh and now we're
independent Pope and the pope was like
that's cute and has Army swiftly crushed
the Rebellion so now saltless bread is a
tradition carried on in the name of
defiance but again this story revolves
around a specific City and saltless
bread is found all over Tuscany plus
there's not a ton of historical evidence
supporting this Sudden Change in bread
baking and there's references to
saltless bread in Tuscany like hundreds
of years before the salt War so